hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast animal models in psychiatry
research
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of labyrinth I'll
be a moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes for
more information please visit WWE have
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker Tracy o
O'Donnell is head of psychiatry
discovery research for the neuroscience
and pain Research Unit and Pfizer
incorporated in Cambridge Massachusetts
dr. O'Donnell who up in Buenos Aires
Argentina and earned his MD and PhD
degrees from the University of Buenos
Aires
dr. O'Donnell worked as a postdoctoral
fellow Anthony Grace at the University
of Pittsburgh where he pioneered studies
on physiological properties and dopamine
control nucleus accumbens in 2013 he
came to Pfizer O'Donnell's research
focuses on the modulation of cortical
brain circuits by dopamine how this
modulation matures during adolescence
and the mechanisms by which it becomes
dysfunctional in rodent models of
psychiatric disorders with the goal of
identifying novel therapeutic targets
advisor dr. O Donnell is driving the use
of psychiatric genetics information to
identify novel therapeutic targets as
well as diverse collaborations with
academic colleagues to advance basic
science and human studies with the
ultimate goal of driving novel
treatments to conditions
hi unmet needs I will now turn it over
to dr. O Donnell for his presentation
hi Brenda thanks for the introduction
it's a pleasure to be part of these lab
roots event what I will be doing today
is provide a little bit of an overview
of some of the work that we and others
have been doing in related to the use of
animal models in psychiatric research
this is the first thing that comes to
mind when one talks about animal models
in psychiatry's of course the question
come with really model psychiatric
disorders enrollment and the honest
answer is probably not but this doesn't
mean that the work that has been done in
the so called and models of
schizophrenia or depression or whatever
the mission we talked about it is useful
and I'm going to go over why and what is
the kind of use we can make out of its
models and give a couple examples of
areas in which we have benefited from
this so the main issue with these
problem perhaps on thinking about an
animal model that produces if conditions
such as schizophrenia or depression is
that these disorders are uniquely human
you know we unless we can ask a rat or
Mouse either here squeaks you know we
cannot really think of our model of
hallucinations or some other components
of these disorders
another thing that complicates the
psychiatry and modeling in terms of
annual work is that usually psychiatric
conditions are quite heterogeneous there
are a number of different components
that go into play
this is not like in pertinency series
where we have a loss of a very specific
cell type like dopamine cells in
schizophrenia for example we have a
number of several different domains that
contribute to the disorder and these are
different symptom clusters can range
from what we call positive symptoms
hallucinations
to apathy and negative symptoms to
cognitive deficits and the idea here is
that these domains really do emerge
because a very well-defined and separate
biological substrate so to pretend that
we can reproduce all these different
domains in one particular animal model
is pliat it's all order and very
difficult to get there on the other hand
I think these different domains for
example cognitive deficits are probably
more amenable to find a an animal
manipulation that brings that up and we
can therefore study and something I
wanted to also emphasize here is that
these ideas that these disorders can be
very understood by in rural domains is
what's driving DN ima initiative our
thoughts or research domain bacteria and
I think the pharmaceutical industry in
general is now embracing this some of
these us at Pfizer are really working to
try to find ways to deal with anomalies
including specific domains not
necessarily on these kind of diagnostic
conditions that are very very complex so
I'm going to work with one particular
domain that's the area in which we've
been working the most and that is
probably somewhat amenable to work in
animal models and this is going to be
the cognitive deficits that are even in
schizophrenia but also in depression
bipolar disorder and many other
conditions and so when I say they are
monopolies because we do know that
cognitive function is the result of very
specific and well-defined brain
circuitry and in particular prefrontal
cortex the it campus and some of those
edges are well conserved across species
and we are obviously this is a field
that is growing and we're gaining more
and more understanding as the technique
the tools we have and are become defined
so we do know that for example for
cognitive performance in peripheral
cortex
tasks we do need a proper balance
between activity in P Daniel sells the
principle neurons the provide output and
the inter neurons which are inhibitory
news that modulate the firing during the
timing themselves and all these balance
is modulated by a number of
neurotransmitters including dopamine
others as we understand more and more
about what are these the secretory basis
of these sanctions then we will find
ways to intervene when these ship become
dysfunctional and perhaps even use
animals in which these secretary becomes
abnormal so you know a key question what
we've been pursuing over the past decade
or so was whether we could really find
animal models animal manipulations in
which we produce an alter excitation in
addition balance in cortical circuitry
and in particular we've been interesting
in in one cell type in part of our
giving positive intelligence
these are inhibitory neurons that are
key to modulate the activity in
circuitry in the cortex in general and
these cells have been repeatedly found
to be abnormal in post-mortem studies in
brains from schizophrenia subjects this
is a cartoon illustrating these and the
data that led to this statement this is
from a preview by Derrick Lewis and
others and what is highlighted here in
colors is the facially these cell types
here and here these are partially
positive in Turners that they have a lot
of markers in brains from patients with
schizophrenia there is a reduction in
the enzyme that synthesizes the
transmitter GABA
there are changes in postsynaptic
receptor density that speak to and a
type of function in this cell population
right and this is one of the most
replicated findings in post-mortem
studies in Slovenia so that is
give me something wrong with these
population so with that in mind so what
would be the usefulness of having an
onion and we look at the caption I have
here is an e on models for schizophrenia
research it's not I'm not trying to make
the case that we're going to present is
work on animal models of schizophrenia
my take here is that because of all the
caveats I started with what we would
have is a manipulation that is a useful
tool to test the specific hypothesis and
in particular I'd be interested in
exploring whether can we reproduce the
loss of our value and internal function
in a Rowland and what are the behavioral
neurochemical and physiological outcomes
of that so again with the mindset of
these loss of internal function we've
been actually a-- we and others have
been working on a number of different
animal models trying to understand what
are the circuitry anomalies that they
did that and in general animal models
have been around for some time the early
ones have been pharmacological I'm fed I
mean use LSD they can provide some sort
of psychotic episode something that
resembles positive symptoms somehow but
the third entry there the PCP which is
an NMDA antagonist and other really
related molecules both in humans and
non-human primates and animals in
general is they can produce a number of
cognitive deficits and the number of
manifestations that look like the sample
so this is perhaps one of the more
apology the moles are still being used
there have been deploying with the
pharmacological models the limitation is
that they do not address the
developmental trajectory of this
disorder is a very particular is
supposed to be a the result of some
developmental
alteration there is a genetic
predisposition that clearly plays a role
and the symptoms emerge usually during
adolescence early episode so there have
been a number of more money
that were putting to play straight to
mimic that developmental trajectory and
those range from some environmental into
such a social isolation leash and models
and some prenatal manipulations and then
lastly there are a number of genetic
models are tapping into the impact that
certain copy number variations or some
specific gene alterations are snips
within specifically regions of the
genome can confer increased risk for
schizophrenia and anyone moles have been
developed to test that again all these
models vary is that they are not
producing the disease but we are truly
tapping onto their useful tools for us
to explore the role of these in
variations the role of the circuitry
that becomes dis laughter in this model
so just to give you an example of how
these models have been put into play for
these notions there is an abnormal
excitation in addition balance in the
cortex this is an example of a DNA media
antagonist as Amala and ketamine is
known to induce a loss of per volume in
staining and DC is an example from a
what hippocampus and you will see on the
lower panels that you have fewer poor
value in project cells here labeled in
yellow this has been found in many many
brain areas not limited to hippocampal
percent cortex as well many different
labs have found out so this is a very
well replicated finding the idea here is
that the antagonism
at the NMDA receptors is probably having
a preferential effect on an MD receptors
that are located in these in theater
intervals and these idea was supported
by work by DT mogul and another's early
on in which she showed that here in this
place for example this is administering
the NMDA antagonist MK 1 into a an awake
animal and what she found was there was
an increase in firing in peroneal cells
which would not be easy to explain with
anonymity antagonist but the
what she was able to do in this study
was to separate cells that were fast
biking like these are supposed to be in
Turners and what she found in these cell
types was a decrease in the firing when
pen in the antagonist were administered
so the explanation for these findings is
that it is the untag amaizing the NMDA
glutamate receptors takes a primary
effect on firing properties of the on
the intelligence and these inter neuron
decreasing firing leads to this increase
in the redline in firing in pyramids so
with this in mind and the idea is that
if we think that in turn ears are
primarily affected in schizophrenia and
that results in an abnormal excite-ation
division balance what the NMD antagonism
is doing is providing us with a tool to
dampen the video of these Fastback an
intervener shown here with the red
circle that will result in an excessive
or abnormal firing in the blue triangles
the principle metallurgic cells that
feel like they are T so in other words
this is what we described as an outer
excitation inhibition balance these
cortex this cortical unit now becomes
dysfunctional because of the lack of
proper balancing by piece in here
interference then the cortex is not
really filtering out recording activity
in mid-step there are many other animal
models in which these some excitation
division balance is effective and I'll
give you just a couple examples this
rapid schizophrenia one this one is a
gene that has been identified as being
truncated in a Scottish family more than
20 years ago and the this is Scottish a
family in which largely 70 percent of
its members have some major psychiatric
condition many of whom are show with
schizophrenia and this one because it's
a truncation 27 several
labs that have produced animal models of
the east concussion and us our cupcakes
has developed a transgenic mice in which
the other expression of the human
truncated this one it induces a learning
that works as a dominant negative and
these mice do show a number of
interesting phenotypes and in particular
I want to highlight here the reduction
in per volume in staining in the frontal
cortex or essentially these animals are
showing again some morphological
evidence or altered in Turners does that
translate another function in the
internals this is something we did
recently as a collaboration with a
Kurosawa and what we had was access to
his this one domain native mice and so
we assessed morphologically again the
specialty these cells are in grade is
per valuing labeling and in green is a
marker for the paranormal nets that's
wrong the interior interviews so the
white edge seems to have a healthy
amount of volume in cells and neural
nets look pretty good whereas on the
right the there some cells that show
purple give me pure dough and the
perineal needs to not look too healthy
they don't have the processes that
normally we have so these are
morphological evidence that the
Parliamentarians this particular model
are impaired and then this was a work
done by a grad student in the lab was
Cara Lee who did wholesale recordings in
these fast biking interneurons and
essentially what he did was to inject
current into the cells and look at their
flying properties and to make a long
story short what we found was that the
firing properties of these cells were
not quite normal their action potentials
were wider they didn't have
the healthy after hyperpolarization that
they show so the biophysics of these
cells are not that right
so in this animal model were observing a
number of changes that suggest this par
value and in Turners are affected work
by many many groups with a different
model now we're talking about a
developmental model also converge on
defining the per volume in engineering
subject and highlighting here the non
rats
these are rats treated in neutral with
methyl oxy methanol a an antibiotic that
prevents microtubule in function and
when these companies delivered in
gestational day 17 there are a number of
adult onset behavioral changes in the
offspring and many labs have contributed
to these work and there is evidence of
other psychotic psyche of
cytoarchitecture in hippocampus are
shown in the right there are a number of
behavioral effects like what you social
interaction cycle of promotion etc but
what I want to highlight here is work
done by ten dodging at any race were in
which they also found a decrease in the
number of per volume in positive cells
in the personal cortex and in the
hippocampus so again this is a neonatal
a prenatal manipulation that it's not
necessarily affecting intimations
directly but it results in loss of
volume in cells once they they found
their adult location after they migrated
so in this case instead of locking in
the receptor and were swapping in type
of function of interneurons
what this mom the mum model what
provides is actually somehow a
developmental manipulation that my
entering news and at the end of the day
these might result in after excitation
something i want to highlight here with
the notion that
we use foreboding staining in these
animals is that bargaining is an
activity dependent market essentially
intervenors make or valuing buffer
calcium they normally fire very rapidly
so they would have a lot of calcium into
it need to buffer it when they don't
fire that much they even need to make
Parvati so it's not having it with use
for ramming staining that's not
necessarily mean the cells are lost that
what it means is the cells are less
active another model we've been working
with and I'm going to elaborate was
spend most of the remaining time up with
this particular is the neonatal ventral
hippocampal region model this is a model
has been around for quite some time was
put forward in the late 80s early 90s by
Barbara lips and a legal burger at the
NIH and this was the drive behind this
model was trying to identify whether
there will be a developmental
manipulation early on that would result
in an adult onset behavioral problem and
Barb and Danny actually did go over a
number of time periods to do to
manipulate developmentally and a number
of regions to kind of interfere with the
developmental trajectory and they came
up with this observation that takes a
relatively narrow window at the end of
the first postnatal week in a rat
during which the ventral hippocampus is
lesion the young the animals then are
returned to their dams and the X naught
and any overt behavioral change until
the animals reached adolescence when
they reach the young adult stage now if
they're become clearly hyperactive they
are hyper sensitive to stress they show
a number of cognitive that is mental
including working memory set shifting
they have other deficits that are
translatable like propulsion addition of
the acoustic startle response and they
have a number of neural chemical
deficits though and the interesting
thing I will be smaller when he worked
for in the early nineties is that they
all do
that is it do emerge during adolescence
like so for the early and manipulation
in the hippocampus is having an impact
on the developmental trajectories or
prefrontal cortical circuits because
these are the behaviors were worth
documented and this is just an
illustration of how the lesion looks
like in general people using this model
go for smallish the smaller relation
that all we need to do is disrupt
hippocampal activity at that critical
developmental stage to have this
profound effect during analysis it
worked we did recently in collaboration
with kinder and Michelle you know in
universe and we were able to show using
unbiased reality that in part valuing
interneurons go down when we compare the
Nina deletion with the the Sham controls
there is from about 40 percent decrease
in per volume in socal again this
doesn't nestling in the cells are done
they are not making per value maybe just
least active and another thing we
observe here is the essentially the in
green WFA is a marker for these
paranormal nets that could be observing
the left in the sham animals but in an
adult animal with a unit lesion now you
do not see as many of those per units
that's around the par value in positive
cells yeah you don't see many
Parcells and this is and below is an
overlay so we also have a decrease in
the count of the peon and positive cells
so what this is telling us is that there
is something wrong this is a
morphological evidence of abnormal
functioning into the population so we
were interested for many years tried to
understand whether these could result in
an abnormal function in the adult animal
and something I was interesting to us in
this regard was the the fact that the
dopamine modulation of these inter
neurons and bohemian cells matures doing
a license so there is a protracted
developmental trajectory and our
prediction was that as these late
development takes place right at the
time in which these new mental Legion
animals and Alan models now show onset
of the case of anomalies perhaps there
may be something affecting these new
will alter their adolescent
developmental trajectory so we know the
opening cells the dopamine original
cortex are mature late and this is
mostly due to work done Quade saying
when he was a postdoc in the lab we have
an interesting observation more than 10
years ago and the dopamine d2 agonist
winter being able to increase find in
classified intelligence so these are
false cell recordings looking at the
excitability the number of action
potentials are induced by current into
these cells and we consistently were
able to see an increase in firing with
the d2 Adams window which was contrary
to the Dogma just time the Plaga knees
are binding to a b2 receptor which is
normally associated with a GI type of G
protein and therefore a victory and that
was indeed the case when we saw we did
report it in very and animals but these
experiments on the Left were done in a
young adult slice and so what we decided
- well was that this excitatory effect
was driven what was something I was
emerging organisms so what we did was to
do this expansion at the number of
different age brackets here and in the
pre-adolescent animals there was not
much of an effect if anything them
perlier Milan in Korea tracker for intro
but when the animals reached adolescence
by the end of the second month of life
we had the emergence of these excitatory
impact now the two Alaniz are able to
increase excitability on these incomes
this is not just something that affects
the interneuron excitability because
were driving this with injecting
currents into the cells this has an
impact on the circuitry so the way we
tested that was here on the left is a
cartoon showing what quiz it was that
stimulating layer one in the cortex and
recording in AP on yourself and he will
get a potentially a an epsp that was
glutamine dependent and then the ec PSP
was attenuated by kwinto
and this animation was blocked by a
particular pilot antagonist so this is
clearly lead to effect this effect was a
lot stronger in the adult animals not
clear in the pre-adolescent animals and
then the duration of this effect was
relatively protracted when the slice he
applied winter for about five minutes
and then the the 20% suppression in the
amplitude of the synaptic response
remained there for a few minutes but
then when he blocked gaba receptors so
taking out of the picture the
contribution of local interneurons the
duration was much shorter so what this
is telling us is that these later part
of the d2 organism news suppression of
these responses is due to the
recruitment of these local engineers so
the way dopamine the two receptors
modulate in imperial cells has both a
composite component that depends on both
literal sectors on the panel so that's
the early
gamma insensitive depression that we see
in the graph and then this is compounded
by the ability of the two receptors to
recruit at the very end
interestingly this is something that is
altered in the new Nottoli tomorrow so
what we would say sure was that the
inside these physiological increase in
firing that we saw in naive animals was
repeated in animals with operation but
in adult animals with an innate elation
now we not only do not see these
increase muscles just stay with the same
firing some even go with a modulation in
the wrong direction
so there is clearly something wrong here
there is we have lost the ability of
pictu Agony's to recruit internals in
this particular model and this is just
to show you straight defining they're
essentially on the sham column disease
the normal maturation from the
pre-adolescent on the left to the other
lesson or young adult population thirty
forty percent increasing excitability
whereas on the individual columns there
is the absence of these developmental
change in which by which these dopamine
containing cells the programming the
neurons the point receptor containing
cells would normally become excited and
now in this model so what happens with
these symmetries in fact that these
excitability changes in inter neurons on
this particular model pretty much what
disease in the sham animals we saw the
same protracted attenuation of epsps as
we showing the naive animals i showed
earlier but in animals with an
inhalation we only see the early part of
the modulation we are not seeing the
lake part so when we have sham animals
in which we block gaba the profile is
the same as in metal lesion animals with
java intact so what we have missed here
is essentially the in evolution model as
has created an adult circuit in which in
communions
cannot be activated by a via t2
modulation so there is something altered
with the Sun population so we saw a loss
of bargaining and we're seeing a lot of
lack of activation in this
electrophysiological testing so again in
the unit lesion model so now instead of
in using a deficit in by pharmacological
means of motivating and B receptors what
we have is again a developmental
manipulation in which we somehow have
impaired the trajectory of these inter
neurons and now they fail to acquire
their adult profile in which they can be
engaged by Delta and the result is an
outer excitation in addition balance
that will come into play whenever
cortical circuits are activated and you
need both the onion cells and classify
chemical names to be engage and motivate
each other so what I think all these
models are are kind of converging on to
is the idea if we think that
schizophrenia has strong genetic
component but with some environmental
aspects coming on top and the idea is
that these combination of genetic and
environmental factors induces anomalies
in synaptic processing in cortical
circuits be them prashanta or campo
these anomalies will likely be tied to
glutamate gala and dopamine processing
so what all these models are doing the
mineral hippocampal region or the
discipline knife suriname manipulation
and many others I haven't what they
converge on is and the inducing by
different means an abnormal circuitry
that can be defined as circuitry that
has lost its balance between excitation
image and the key element and these
see abnormal symmetries probably be
these are very impulsive fast biking
interneurons then now cannot be
activated or maybe they're high quality
and therefore you have this loss of
valuing and these are not even in the
models in which the manipulations are
done early like well it's the mum or
this one or deletion these anomalies are
not evident until the animals reached
the end at world stage so that's why I
enter these line they're saying that
internals maybe love I don't there may
be something wrong with engineers but
they are still functional and it's only
when they see neurons that maybe below
go should go through they are very
adolescent maturation they just failed
to do that and now is when this
circuitry becomes abnormal and unable to
cope with the demands of the activity
when you get the transition between
adolescence and young adult and could
lead to a number of behavioural symptoms
and what is makes these model attractive
is that the this is precisely the river
enter stage in which most psychiatric
conditions have and extinct and onset
bipolar disorder schizophrenia
depression so the notion that this
symmetry in critical cortical regions
goes into this lake migration relations
makes them quite vulnerable and if you
can think that there are already
vulnerable cell types like they are
spiking purple connotes then we could
think of these as what may be driving
some potentiality and for a sake of time
I'm not going to show the data but as
and many others shown a number of
behavioral consequences of manipulative
inter neurons in many of these models
whether is this one model than unity
lesion the model or just simple taking
interneurons online/offline
by number of opto genetic manipulation
for example what all these manipulations
also conversion is in showing in number
of prefrontal cortex hippocampal depend
behaviors that become wonderful now if
this is true now essentially what I'm
trying to put forward is this notion
that loss of internal function and the
oddity ensuing loss of altered balance
and excitation addition is this
something that then it is a conversion
finding among all these models right so
the idea is you might have multiple
etiologies coming on to affecting these
one particular neural cell type and
together with the postmodern data I I
highlighted earlier that showing loss of
volume in staining for example it may be
true that these cells are you know white
has specific and primary effect in these
conditions so is there any way to
restore function in some of these models
by questioning activity in decent renews
this is something were now currently
testing and but we were able to do some
of that again in the collaboration with
Kingdom you know in that we actually
started asking the question of what
makes
interneurons vulnerable during this
adolescent developmental stage and based
on Kim and Michelle's work over the
years it really likely hypothesis to us
was the idea that these neurons because
they're so active they're so
metabolically demanding they might go
through oxidative stress at a critical
time and then that might render them
sick and dysfunction so we did start a
collaboration with the fan and the idea
was essentially to induce deletion at
the end of the first postnatal week in
rats have some control animals in which
we did not have yet the symptoms person
behavior anomalies are not there in the
these juvenile ace or no 21 but this age
group was going to allow us to test
whether the internals were very sick
they are not I mean if there is
something abnormal within before the
symptom onset then we would let the
animals go through their adolescent
developmental period and then test them
again when they're young and to test
whether it's a phase was playing a ball
in some way the behavioral end points
and the logical end points we did test a
group in which we treated with a
glutathione precursor in a second system
and again this is data were cutting what
I already showed the loss of during
staining in the adult grill there was
not so much of a loss for valuing in the
pre-adolescent workshop p21 this is
before purity there was not a clear
change in but what's interesting in the
black is the control animals what we had
is an increase in particle density from
the juvenile to begin adult and that was
not present in the new evolution animals
it looks like in these animals somehow
we impaired the ability of the cells to
go through this adolescent when we treat
animals with NAC now what we had was so
what we had was a essentially we've
recovered you know in red to the right
were showing a decrease in value in
staining the new nipple lesion animals
and in blue is actually the density of
per volume yourselves in the new nipple
lesion animals that we see the
antioxidant so we were able to prevent
the loss of progeny in these animals in
the adult animals that were trading with
the interaction so this is showing this
is a strong indication that actually
stressed maybe playing a wall in at
least the loss of her valued extinct
this is again the same data but now
we're focusing on actual market epoxy
assessed this is in in green is a toxic
easy and marker of oxidized and oxidized
base and you could see are the dramatic
increase in the enve HL right here come
but you don't see that you prevent that
of say stress if you treat the animals
with NHC this is in the juvenile p21
you're seeing quite remarkable ox a
stress levels at the time in which part
of even cells have not gone down yet so
this is to me evidence that these cells
are getting sick but they're still
somewhat function but if we treat the
animals with an AC to the right were
preventing the emergence of oxidized and
this in the adult there are still some
you know lesions show some degree of
toxic stress that could be happening
I'll highlight is the par value in
Tunisia and with him and Michelle we
didn't really look at the number of
other interneurons so this is just to
highlight the proportion of our volume
in cells are showing OTA stress in
rarely seen Damien evolution so it's
about 50 percent of our argument cells
show this a table service DG marker box
a stress but we were not able to detect
oxidize in neither quarantine or carve
an unwinding position so these seems to
be somewhat selective evolving we also
lost so a loss of these thirty neural
Nets that I liked earlier and you look
at the merge English in the bottom
eventually what we found was the Indian
unity lesion animals there is less for
evolving in rare unless that you know
net in green unless we treat them with
NHC where we work
were normal levels of our valuing on top
and personal nets on the bottom so
treating these animals with an
antioxidant during development will
prevent the loss of programming prevents
of serious emergence and parents the
loss of these paranoid
is there a physiological impact of all
this so this is an experiment like the
one I started with synaptic responses
within cortical circuitry you could see
on the Left essentially we have these
small attenuation of epsps that's our
dependent it is gone in the neonatal
lesion model unless we treat the animals
with an EC and this is a quantification
of the responses here so essentially the
these physiological attenuation of
synaptic responses that depend on
protruding inter neurons in normal
animals is lost in the model but we can
prevent it with an antioxidant
suggesting these objects stress that we
can detect on these intervals and I have
an impact on the functionality of
pictures just to go quickly about some
other endpoints that may be may have
some translational value in this animal
we were able to assess mismatch
negativity mismatch negativity is an
event related potential that you could
detect in response to stimulus an
auditory stimulus and it's news in the
clinic essentially it's a pre-attentive
measure that relates to salience ease of
inputs for example you send a tone
repeatedly into a subject or an animal
you will get an Evoque potential in
shown in in blue below that we weekly
nine and we can measure essentially the
negativity and deflection induced by
these stimulus right here and then
whenever we send that they all this is
say an average of responses to hundreds
of tons of the same frequency and
amplitude and duration but then every
now and then we send the tone that has a
different village like whether is or a
different frequency
and because it's different these
earpiece wanted to detect that salience
here that signal by increasing the
negativity on this way
so we can subtract this two-way pump and
that the outcome is dismissed much
activity interestingly this is a
something that reduces schizophrenia
patients even early on in the disease
which highlight state the nature of
difficulty and assigning salience II
automatically to stimuli so we decided
to test I mean there ha ha there has
been couple ribs that I were able to set
up this much negativity in Rowlands so
we went on to test it in these are
animal model literally when was it
that's even in the lab who did this work
and will were able to see it was in
control animals there is something real
mismatch negativity essentially the this
attenuation from the red to the to the
blue and what you will see here is
essentially in the graphs with the area
under the curve there is the subtraction
between in the shaded area shows some
degree of mismatch negativity in control
animals it is reduced in animals with an
inner deletion so you see the two way
from negative welcomed pretty much of
nothing and this is recovered or
expressing in neonate lesion animals
that were trading with antes with NAC
the little point occurs so antioxidant
treatment not only helped with a local
symmetry it also helps preventing these
abnormal evoked potential that has
translational value these another
measure a behavioral measure that also
has translational value is these
proportion edition of the acoustic style
response and here in black is the
proposed inhibition and you know this is
a sterile response attenuation with a
pre exposing animals to it tone and in
black is the normal response the higher
the tone of a background the more likely
the startle response is going to be
attenuated neonatal lesion animals show
a reduction di is very consistent
finding across many large very well
replicated finding
so we saw that decreased except when the
lesion animals have been treated with an
AC so antioxidant treatment can also
prevent the emergence of this behavior
miss the proposed innovation deficit so
all these data actually highlights the
notion that antioxidant treatment can
protect against these adult in time but
we've been we've been treating the
animals through development right so if
we want to make a case that this is
relevant for early intervention in
schizophrenia for example well we cannot
start treatment in young kids right so
we normally detect the anomalies or the
behavioral symptoms but when you're
doing a list so we went on to repeat
some of these experiments but now
treating the animals with analysis and
only during adolescence where we able to
see an impact there and the answer is
yes so in black you see the Purple's in
addition deficits in the control animals
in red is the so in black is the normal
dpi in red is the deficit in Venice in
mph are at an inflow is the reversal of
the deficit with the antioxidant so in
this case I can talk about reversal
because we started treatment when the
antioxidant the loss of a bottoming was
already place so this gives us hope that
maybe even treating it is valuing that
is induced condition parts could be
present to California when we are able
to detect the behavioral deficits is a
possible we did the same with a
different type of antioxidants go over
this quickly but assigning is NADPH
oxidase inhibitors so it taps on to also
stress the different mechanism and here
again we were able to see in yellow the
reversal of the world deficit in the
unit position animals and epsilon P
significant peroxidase mimic that also
showed the ability to reverse PP axis so
ensure what I think in this project
model and this is common to many of them
it's not we can see that there is a
population of cells the Piranha
important onion cells that are affected
even before symptoms come online and
their alteration will be made evident by
measuring the levels of oxygen stress
but these cells are being sick but not
is functional yet all the behaviors that
depend on providing in terminals are
still intact it's only an animal growth
through their developmental maturation
that now there are anomalies these
failure on B cell type activity could
bring the concept and then we can look
at loss while weaving staying in there's
still some of these stress all the
Lessing things that you know so these
are cartoon kind of summarizes a little
bit where I see the convergence of all
these findings if we think that the
circle represents at par vollen
interneuron and mitochondria here
represents the kind of metabolic
energetic demand of these cells we could
have a loss of function of these cells
by many different means including
blocking and the receptors interfering
with a inputs like in the unit or lesion
mobile development we could have against
aesthetic NMDA antagonist can induce the
same problem we can have other things I
didn't tap onto which is brought in
inactivation that is immoral that in
case in maternal Indian occupation that
drives increased cytokines and again
induces oxidized finish doing positive
interneurons so there are many ways in
which this particular cell by could be
affected so these could account for a
number of different etiologies but the
final common pathway is going to be this
alter excitation in division that might
be cells so I started with this question
can we model psychiatric condition
balance and when my initial answer was
no I
should not be too strong about that
because I think all the data I reveal
and there's one more up along the same
lines show that we can use animal
manipulations to induce a specific
pathophysiological condition that may be
of relevance to disease so we're not
getting I is schizophrenic rat or mouse
no certainly no but what we were able to
do is specifically test the impact of
one type of physiological condition the
loss of value in internal function and
what is the behavior Olympic and we
modulate that we can we find ways to the
worst PR activity so with that in mind
then yes animal models are useful tools
tools to test this kind of hypothesis
and I think they still offer a lot of
value in terms of our ability to think
about new target new ways to treat these
disorders and specifically I mean I've
even using the term schizophrenia
because that's the way we started and
people keep using putting the inter
neuron dysfunction in the realm of
schizophrenia pathophysiology but this
applies not just to see the perennial
atole to cognitive performance that can
be alter in a number of psychiatric
conditions so we're trying to keep model
easy say a domain dysfunction in the
common area and with that actually the
people who did the work and our
collaborators bar reliefs and Alan Berg
at NIH and Kim Dao Michel van Rijn young
along the hall and at the University of
Lausanne and without this point were
operationally the clear cell and thank
you all for your attention thank you dr.
O'Donnell for bringing that important
information to us before we get started
with our questions and we have a few I
just want to remind our audience to
click the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window and
submit your questions definitely our
first question is it the country
fusion of puberty changes that make
interneuron vulnerability or is it below
numbers in the neonatal period um there
have been there have been some attempts
to answer that question it is say it's
really a difficult one because the
attempts I know of had been trying to
manipulate the you know hormonal changes
during puberty to see if we could
minimize some early and these particular
manipulations and the if they in a
little lesions animals for example with
a gonna rectum II the deficits still
emerge they may be delayed but they
still emerge so it's not necessarily the
hormonal changes during adolescence it's
more likely to be some sort of
programmed coming online or on some
specific gene backwards
great thanks moving on to our next
question is there a way to enhance the
carb albumin numbers
that's an interesting thing we did I
mean I think in your acting about
enhancing above normal levels I don't
I'm not aware of that being a
possibility what we were able to see is
maybe a time precursor treatment we were
able to bring the programming numbers
back to normal in the adult animals that
were treated with with NAC so if you
think that those animals were bound to
have low levels of our bargaining
multi-streaming yes did enhance the
number of cells showing thought about it
but I said as I said in the presentation
there is a social you lose lots of
surviving staining doesn't mean the
cells are not there right so the fact
that we're able to see an increase in
providing staining an Indonesian animals
when we treat them with an exe suggests
that the loss of her gardening is
because the cells are just high pocketed
make certain they are not needing to
express for valium in Tubac ecology
maybe that if we let them grow and we're
going to older animals the cells might
start becoming effective we might lose
them but you know that the question is
still whether we can have treatments
that can bring all these interns up at
different stages we are there any other
trials with NAC treatment actually yes
there there are there have been a couple
studies with NAC in patients they study
with Kindle and Michael Burke in
Australia in which they showed some
benefit with NAC in some patients
including a reversal of the mismatch
negativity deficits the
patients showed I dunno there are couple
ongoing trials with an AC at this point
the problem with an AC and I didn't
highlight these in my presentation is
that when you give an AC to a normal
brain in the Arsham animals now you're a
you might induce oxy a stress so in
other words too much of a good thing can
be a bad name so Reddick's pathways are
very tightly balanced so increasing
glutathione bi NAC on the redox system
that's well balanced may become pure
oxidant
so that's why we did see increasing of
say stress markers in our control
animals we can exceed so I'm bringing
this up because in terms of NAC as a
possible treatment we need to be careful
we might need to select the patients
that have a clear red ox deficit if not
with risk inducing something as worse
than boy working to correct the question
actually I didn't highlight the fact
that in many of our measures actually we
were having the antioxidants off by the
time we were doing the measures
NAC in particular has another caveat
which is also works through it affects a
glutamine cysteine exchanger so you can
change luta make levels so we have an
ACM board when we're looking at synaptic
physiology example if the effects can be
compounded not by the the antioxidant
profile but by the glutamatergic program
so in most of these measures we had the
animals of NAC for a week or two and we
were able to see still the effect now
we're trying to extrapolate these to
patient I would assume that we might not
need continuous NAC
but probably according census we are
able to monitor a Redick state there may
be a fox in which may we might need
antioxidant and then we can let it go
for some time and then again so you may
be the way I see this is more like
acting on demand people can't find the
right biomarker to the track to give us
the information under well at stake I do
not think this needs to be a continuous
for life great we have time for just one
question our attendee asks would you
expect the same effects if NAC was given
in adulthood that actually that's a very
important question we have not done that
but I am aware of other groups now
having tested NAC in different animal
models and I know Kim doe has been
collaborating with people that has done
work with many of these other models
that give these information deficits
that includes the memorize the thermal
limit activation dollars and in some of
those actually the antioxidant treatment
has been initiated about animals and
were still ahead so probably that that
really actually makes us hopeful that an
antioxidant based approach who would be
worth of all by the time we reach
diagnosis in patients great I'd like to
thank dr. O Donnell again for bringing
this information to us in this web
seminar and just ask him do you have any
final comments for our attendees today
well I mean this was just a snapshot of
things that have been done in my lab and
others this is still an evolving field
there is a lot that we can still learn
from these developmental manipulations
and I think we're on the path to find
ways to work you know help patients with
these disasters devastating disorders
great thank you so much I'm gonna let
our audience know that today's webcast
will be available on-demand viewing from
through September of 2016 you'll receive
an email from laggards alerting you when
this webcast is available for on-demand
replay and we would invite you to
forward that email to your colleagues
who may have missed out on today's live
event thank you very much for logging in
and joining us today
hope to see you next time goodbye